[Music]
what's up everyone so Marvel for the
most part has done a pretty good job at
keeping pretty much anything related to
spider-man far from home a secret the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway still
continues if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero I'll be picking
another winner this week we know a bit
about the movie but really nothing has
been confirmed we don't even know if it
takes place before or after Avengers
infinity war and or before or after
Avengers 4 and unfortunately this leaked
video does not really give us any
answers but it is nice to see samuel l
jackson and Cobie Smulders on scene
there's no audio to this film but as you
can see here they're both walking and
then agent Hill gets a notification on
her phone that stops them both in their
tracks you can see Nick Fury's right
hand go up clearly asking what's going
on and then he throws both of his hands
in the air clearly not excited about the
news they got now again there's no audio
so we don't really know what they're
saying but my guess is that something
related to Mysterio I'm assuming since
Nick Fury and Maria Hill are in
spider-man far from home they are still
working for shield and they're going to
be teaming up with Peter Parker to try
and stop Mysterio again this video
doesn't really shed any light on whether
or not spider-man far from home will
take place before the events of Avengers
infinity war or after it's obviously
highly speculated that everybody that
turned to dust
in Avengers infinity war will be brought
back somehow in offenders for so what do
you all think let me know your thoughts
on this leaked video and let me know if
you think spider-man far from home will
take place before infinity war or after
another reminder about the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway if you'd like to enter
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video comment below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]